c'est le couple macron aime passer des
coups de fil à tout le show business
après brigitte et son appel très
remarquée à nabila pour la féliciter de
sa solidarité il ya quelques semaines
c'est maintenant au tour du président de
la république
emmanuel macron de faire parler de lui
après une conversation téléphonique avec
jean marie bigard c'est sur facebook que
l'humoriste a révélé s'être entretenu
avec le chef de l'état
mes amis certains journalistes me tourne
en ridicule depuis plusieurs jours
puisque j'ai réussi à parler à maquereau
téléphone pour qu'il puisse écouter ma
colère qui est aussi celle de millions
de personnes
avant de conclure avec véhémence jeu
peut-être pas la carte de presse mais
moi j'ai encore une paire de une colère
relative à la fermeture des bars qu'il
avait exprimé dans une vidéo
pourquoi on rouvre pas les barre haut
pour ce serait pas mal au bas on sait
aussi se tenir comme dans le métro comme
dans le train un échange suite auquel
emmanuel macron aurait donné raison à
l'humoriste en déclarant on va changer
de stratégie alors emmanuel macron
appelle jean marie bigard choqué au pas
choquer les quais choqué qui n'est pas
choqué bernard montiel on va démarrer
par vous puisque vous êtes le porte
parole du gouvernement
oui alors oui après bigard je suis pas
choqué du tout je trouve ça très normal
parce que d'abord monsieur macron le
présent dans le public est un homme
populaire qui aime les choses populaire
et tout ce qui est populaire
l'intéressent et il était normal il
n'est pas sectaire d'appeler bigard par
rapport à ça puisque la contestation la
provocation de bigard c'était justement
à propos des bars il avait raison
puisque toute façon ils vont rouvrir les
bas alors il ya ce matin je vous le dis
il ya l'ancien président françois
hollande fils a taclé à ce sujet sur
france inter ce matin
bon après françois hollande est là il
est plus là c'est normal un messie tacle
après voilà moi je vous dis après si je
peux comprendre les gens qui dit faux
qu'il appelle faut qu'il appelle tout le
monde après mais regardez ce qu'a dit
françois hollande
les médias qu'on appelle eric zemmour
jean marie bigard et gère le puy du fou
personnellement avec philippe de
villiers un président doit-il parle à
tout le monde voulait dire la prison ne
doit pas téléphoner comme ça c'est
possible
voilà c'est tout ce qu'il a dit voilà
bon c'est will valérie batou tous les
tous les présidents ont rappelé qu on
appelle les leaders d'opinion mitterrand
appelait sarkozy appelait françois
hollande se sache je suis certaine qu'il
le faisait également mais lui se tromper
de françois hollande il appelait des
gares et par ailleurs on peut pas te
reprocher tout et son contraire au
précédent c'est à dire que à un moment
on a dit il est hors sol ben n'écoute
pas ce que dit la france et quand entre
guillemets les leaders d'opinion ils
sont suivis par des grands groupes de
fans et de tweetos par exemple comme
jean marie bigard on les appelle on dit
maintenant pourquoi il appelle donc dans
les deux cas il est perdant quoi
jean-michel alors moi je suis moi je
suis très choquée moi chaussée la
dictature du buzz qui est mort
malheureusement représente at il une
société actuelle où les réseaux sociaux
ou le buzz médiatique a plus
d'importance que les vraies idées voilà
donc si c'était un boulanger qui avait
une cave et un discours sincère et qui
avait fait des débuts il n'aurait jamais
appelé la paix parce que j'aurais eu
milliards ce que ça à people voilà donc
il a plu comme ça et je suis désolé
c'est ça icorn la fonction
présidentielle
j'imagine pas de gaulle à l'époque ap
chantal ladesou pour lui dire ah oui
paris qu'un problème dont je sais pas
quoi il aura bel et bien pris la villa
n'a fait qu'y luxe il a raison il a
continué ses six mais ça aussi je le
rappelais sarkozy d'appeler tout le
monde leur cause i am est pas le
regarder voir le pape mais c'est bien
sûr ça peut bien sûr il a envoyé bigard
voir le pape a envoyé plein de gens
kelly ils ont déjà tout se fait comme
suit 10 n'appellera pas le boulanger moi
je pense que si mme boulanger il avait
fait 7 millions de vues voilà il avait
autant et je pense que là peut-être
qu'il aura le ballon j'ai là le besoin
fallait donc ça me soldats le boulanger
ça me choque pas du tout que le
président appelle jean marie billa moi
par contre ce qui me choque c'est que
les les personnalités seul vente et le
disent aussi oui mais attendez j'adore
jean-marie mais vos potes mais on ne dit
pas je vous le dit pas il ya des choses
qui se parlent d'un terme sert le peuple
jean marie bigard et aide le peuple
auprès du président mais pourquoi tu vas
le dire les réseaux sociaux d'accord je
pense que ça enlève tout le charme de
cet accent juste moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec kelly là
dessus franchement vu jean-marie qu'est
mon pote absolue fait pas il fait des
émissions avec moi ces voix là il fait
preuve de la borne fait partie de mon
équipe j'ai toujours défendu le génial
là dessus je suis désolé moi je pense
qu'il ne faut pas
dire qu'il compenserait bon moi je pense
qu'ils aient jean-marie là il a trahi
emmanuel macron parce qu'il a balancé il
a dit qu'il l'avait appelé mais moi je
dit aussi qu emmanuel macron n'a pas
appelé jean marie bigard je suis
totalement contre que mon président de
la république appelle un humoriste vous
ai parlé du boulanger se trouve que
macro rappeler un boulanger à lyon va
c'est vrai il a appelé il a raison de
visioconférence avec un boulanger moi je
préfère un emmanuel macron capelle les
chefs qui appelle esteves kalmthout ses
chefs
il a dit comment il assure qu'il
appelait bigard il a pas de restaurants
billard il veut juste aller boire des
verres il veut juste revivre de toute
façon les salles créent des gens mais
oui manger une côte de boeuf son terrain
ça on va le faire qui s'inquiètent pas
c'est que ça les mecs qui veulent son
livre tous sont pressés d'aller boire
des coups c'est tout on va le faire vous
inquiétez pas je travaille dans la
restauration
je suis pressée au travail dans la
région ont retravaillé je vais qui c'est
là je suis pressé j'ai la chance d'être
là mais je veux retravaille mode macro
il appelle biya ça me va pas du tout
bigard n'a pas de restaurant bigard ne
fait pas partie du comité des restants
il ya des tas de restaurateurs avec qui
j'ai parlé au téléphone talent pour rien
chose à dire le pays notamment aux
assurances complaints de choses à dire
alors billard et des gentils c'est notre
pote c'est votre pote
y'a pas de soucis mais arrête de gueuler
comme sa désertion des restaurants ça va
se faire et nord et la crds on arrête
d'appeler bigard demain il va appeler
qui m'a dit j'ai parlé de bouder boudin
la plein de choses à dire sur la
couverture appel bouder c'est leur dada
zed en marche a expliqué ce matin que la
volonté des manuels mâcon était d'être
le président de tous les français
auraient fait pour ça qu'il a fait ça là
comme c'est vraiment quand on est
président de la république
heureusement qu'on peut appeler
n'importe quel citoyen heureusement
qu'on peut échanger avec n'importe quel
citoyen quoi de plus naturel d'aller
échanger avec des personnes et encore
plus quand des personnes ne sont pas
justement dans la ligne politique du
président la république ou du groupe
majoritaire alors je vous donne et on
s'est procuré les coulisses de cet appel
d' emmanuel macron un jean marie bigard
alors sachez qu'au début jean marie
bigard pensais que c'était une blague
quand il a entendu le message des
manuels macro sur son répondeur
ce qu'il a laissé un message sur son
répondeur emmanuel macron c'est patrick
sébastien qui a confirmé à bigard qu
emmanuel macron cherché à le joindre
la conversation a duré dix minutes il
pensait se prendre un gros coup de
pression après des coups de gueule très
violente bigard et pourtant le président
lui aurait dit qu'il était d'accord avec
lui qu'il allait changer de strates
j jean marie bigard dévoilera
l'intégralité de la conversation lors
d'un spectacle en juin
voilà ça c'est très bien alors ça
m'arrive je kiffe un jeu l'adorent mais
voilà c'est urgent en est la meilleure
preuve que c'est choquant qu'on
m'appelle c'est que jean marie muller
lui-même était choquée qu'il le rappelle
donc c'est bien que si on marche sur la
tête
moi je veux qu'elle était surprise des
surprises c'est normal il a fait 2
repose au 2 bd qui m'a appelé le
président implique donc de ce mec c'est
pas normal c'est logique c'est que c'est
un président ouvert il s'adresse à tout
le monde faut bien parler des figures
antisystème comme le sont bigard de
villiers et même eric zemmour qu'il a
appelée à suite à son accrochage système
avec les noms que tu as dis là je rigole
l'anticipaient à la commande il ya comme
une des ministères elle avait qualifié
antisystème il avec elle demande à ce
qu'un tueur la paix mondiale fois pour
qui le minent la culture par la vigueur
oui alors voilà on va voir ce qu'on
pense des téléspectateurs juste
j'aimerais avoir l'avis d'amina là
dessus moi je pense que emmanuel macron
a le droit d'appeler qu'yves d'accord
voilà donc ça vous choque pas qu'il
appelait jean mayer moi ce qu'il
rattrape moi je vous le dis c'est qu'il
appelait ce boulanger il l'a dit raymond
il appelait boulanger il a appelé voilà
il appelle des cas des gens voilà qui
met moi je suis un peu d'accord avec
kelly et je vous dit jean marie c'est
mon frère quand je vous dis à mon frère
c'est mon ami et je le dégeler des fonds
du tout le temps vous avez vu des chaque
fois qu'il a eu des problèmes je le
défendrai toujours leur mari parce que
c'est mon avis mon frère juste c'est
vrai que je peux comprendre qu' il
fallait pas qu'il le dise mine de rien
le président tu appelles voilà tu es tu
vas tu lui as que le point de commencer
bernard montiel que le président de la
république est un petit peu énervé que
jean marie bigard et dévoilé le fait
qu'il appelait alors sincèrement je ne
le sais pas moi je sais que ça m'amuse
beaucoup quand geneviève de fontenay
raconte aussi qu'elle là tout le temps
au téléphone
ouais bon là ça fait quelques temps
après geneviève de fontenay on sait pas
si c'est vrai ou pas non mais c'est vrai
que geneviève lavoie là il paraît qu'ils
répondent à ces sms
il parlera oui à 9 heures du matin ils
appellent donald trump à 9h30 il appelle
le président de corée du nord à 10
heures il appelle à vous c'est là que
vous êtes
exactement c'est là où tout donne raison
à tous ceux qui disent qu'il est gay il
devrait voilà l'appareil avait dit
nathalie lafaye noro on avance le
président c'est de nous diriger le monde